I woke up and I said to my daughter  we're gonna buy a watch and she's like  why are we going to buy a watch I said  well because I have to collapse the wave  function and she's like what the heck  does that mean Dad whenever I feel this  anxiety and I have this big challenge  coming up most people would sort of like  go for the idea of I if I achieve  something I'm going to give myself the  reward I decided to put the card in  front of the horse and give myself the  reward because I understood that  embodying and being the thing I wanted  to achieve was tantamount to actually  achieving it so I bought this really  nice watch and it was a a reward for  having overcome in the future the thing  I hadn't achieved yet damn every time I  look at my watch I'm gonna remember the  thing that I've already achieved  as if it had already happened